I
I really like to thank the organizers
for inviting me to present today and I'd
like to thank you for making the time to
attend this presentation I am going to
explore the question as to whether or
not animal study workflow software that
more closely emulates clinical trial
approaches can actually help improve the
predictability of clinical outcome after
that I'll be showing the software that
we use as well and if you're interested
in a more detailed look please feel free
to contact me be happy to meet with you
the problem is we have an unacceptably
high failure rate in late phase clinical
trials and following clinical trials we
have an abysmal five percent approval
rate of any cancer therapeutics it may
be surprising to you to know that it is
primarily due to a lack of demonstrated
efficacy as opposed to toxicity the why
such poor predictability well it's
really simple our traditional approaches
to how we do efficacy testing and the
tools that we use to test them differ
significantly from clinical trials we
have significant differences in the
study designs so hodgepodge of various
protocols are being run differently with
different parameters being run different
sizes different scopes different
subjects such as going more for more
homogenous subjects genetically as well
as homogenous diseases that we're
testing so using the Xena graphs or and
and really not reflecting what is seen
in the clinic and also the how we enroll
in animals for example is more on a
synchronized basis as opposed to a
rolling enrollment as you seen in the
clinic and the analytical reporting
methods are not as clinically relevant
as they could be and this is driven
primarily due to the limitations in our
traditional animal study conduct tools
which unfortunately still in 2015 are
excel-based with a hodgepodge of other
analytical approaches such as graphpad
prism or r or SAS and we see a great
number of labs that are still using
paper plus Excel
so effectively we're using a more manual
approach with Excel and these other
tools this leads to significant
inconsistencies across labs and even
within a single investigator from one
study to the next which prevents cross
study comparisons little great deal of
an efficiency because of all the manual
steps that are involved and there's
never enough time every researcher I
know never has enough time and that's
really due to the tools that they're
using and their limitations data
integrity has impacted mistakes happen
we see mr. errors in recording and
transcription copying data and they
remain undetected and for example we
recently encountered one of our
customers that asked us to make a report
based on one of their excel macros
they've been using for 10 years and we
found two major mistakes and those and
they didn't know for 10 years we also
see scientific misconduct it is rare but
it does happen we're hearing more and
more about it on the news and impacts
the integrity of the entire study one
example was a case of well I'll just say
scientific misconduct that was
undetected for a number of years and it
cost the company between two and five
million dollars so it's rare but it does
happen and because of how the data is
collected notebooks and Excel
spreadsheets it's usually only available
to the originator and to no one else it
remains in these data silos which are by
design unsearchable if you can't find
data it's effectively discarded and that
is a tremendous waste of data research
resources animals time money all of
things which are really precious and
difficult to come by day increasingly
also we have a really significant lack
of interconnectedness and integration
which limits how we can run our animal
studies more like animals clinical
trials so to conduct tools by using a
common study protocol and methodology
under a common software application
database we
can improve the method so increase
subject diversity disease diversity such
as tumor diversity the methodology such
as enrollment approaches and study sizes
etc and these can more closely emulate
clinical approaches so the conclusion is
because technology is still very new
it's not yet been proven but it is
highly likely and stands to reason that
by more closely emulating clinical
approaches with improved technology that
we can improve the clinical outcome
predictability so a new technological
approach involves using a common study
protocol across multiple researchers or
within an organization or within
organization that's worldwide it really
doesn't matter instead of having a
hodgepodge of various study designs you
have a single study design where you can
run multiple studies if you have
limitations at one site you can run
those at other sites as well and then
combine all of those studies and that
data under the single protocol you can
employ multiple treatment arms such as
having multiple pdx lines per model this
helps increase the N or the power and
increased power leads to increased
predictability or improved
predictability thereby piggyback studies
and then we can employ rolling
enrollment approaches much more like a
much more clinically relevant we can use
randomization analytical and reporting
that visitor much more clinically
similar and those methods and results
can then be saved into a database where
they're securely preserved they're
accessible by stakeholders the
information can be distributed but much
much more easily but they're available
there's securely preserved in perpetuity
where they're also available to be
searched so labs don't unnecessarily
reproduce studies we see quite a bit of
that better that the traditional
approach using existing spreadsheets
graphing and analytical tools and has
been clearly too complex to manage two
studies reflecting
clinical research workflow so we have a
five percent approval rate of any cancer
therapeutics we've been using the same
tools and doing it the same way for
30-plus years yet expecting a different
result so doing it for 30 years or
longer I am the person on the left in
case you can don't recognize me and by
virtue of attending this presentation
you are clearly not two people on the
right study log solution our study log
animal study workflow software and
database makes it feasible for the first
time in history to conduct multi-site
multi-armed preclinical trials with
randomized rolling enrollment or
synchronized enrollment using a common
centralized protocol the application is
designed specifically by scientists to
automate and facilitate the oversight
and most importantly to mirror the
workflow of animal studies in oncology
and multiple disease areas we have
researchers using it in infectious
disease such as Ebola inflammation
neuroscience toxicology metabolism etc
which speaks to the flexibility of the
application and the applicability of it
so it's a powerful system allowing you
to oversee and conduct studies knowing
exactly what's going on a day to day to
day basis as i said the software is
extremely flexible into the hallmark of
our software design process we know that
changes always happen on a study they
must happen because you can get two
answers much more quickly by being able
to analyze in real time as a study is
being conducted and get get two answers
more quickly and then you can ask
subsequent questions of a study and so
that allows you to do more studies and
save on resources animals of time etc so
flexibility is the key we have a
comprehensive scheduling system which
allows you to schedule let's say a
synchronous lyra assigned animals into a
study or different treatments that each
have their own schedule that's very
important to know and for users that are
running these studies they can very
easily see what the schedules are and
when they come in in the morning what is
to be done what's to be done at the end
of the day if something was missed and
should it colleague not show up what
duties need to be covered for them so it
makes life a lot easier it helps lower
stress level and improves planning you
can easily align analyze asynchronously
collected data and we use clinically
relevant distribution and randomization
methods such as multi parameter
randomization stratified sampling these
can be done synchronously or you can
randomize on an asynchronous or
iterative basis such as done in the
clinic as you have newcomers or new
subjects available to be used on a study
so this is again more clinically
relevant we have an audit trail tracking
every change in the study so that during
the study or long after the study you
know exactly who did what when where and
how we have a system architecture that
allows for a single user on a single
laptop to use a software for very small
labs you have a lot of small labs using
it or you can have very large
multinational organizations as depicted
in this architecture description where
you have a single centralized server and
database that synchronizes with that in
this case three different sites with
their own database and then multiple
laptops and or web portals collecting
data or changing the designs or
accessing the information all the
synchronizing to the database on each
site software allows for the design of
studies users can input their
randomization methods or distribution
methods the group's the number of
animals the types of animals what are
the subjects are using if they're using
wild types and transgenic all of that
information the housing bedding cajon
conditions the treatment
description so drugs or treatments or
drug combinations they can also input
the disease induction methods whether
that be a pdx or a syngeneic ala graph
or chemically induced tumor as well as
they can create or customize their own
numerical values that they like to
collect or measure so they can be scores
or but measured values such as net body
weight or let's say serum biomarker
levels or any sort of new numerical
value you like to collect users can view
the study as can't stakeholders
designated personnel such as technicians
are allowed to collect data you have to
be authorized to collect data or to be
assigned to a study for the specific
role you can change data if you can
collect that you can propose an
amendment which are amendments are today
de are approved as are the mem
instituted the study designs data can be
reviewed and if the reviewer sees an
animal is an outlier they can actually
exclude that data or that that single
data point or that data type for that
animal or if an animal has been
accidentally miss toast and is
essentially a protocol deviation they
can exclude the entire animal from all
subsequent graphs and analysis so users
can create graphs just a click of a few
buttons they can analyze and create
reports and data exports and a variety
of formats all with just a few clicks in
a very consistent manner they can view
the study history again so you know
exactly who did what when where in-house
there is accountability and this really
does help mitigate the chances for any
sort of scientific misconduct study
templates could be employed so any study
can be created and turned into a study
template so you have consistent study
designs or you can also clone or copy
aesthetic design very easily to quickly
recreate a new study based off an old
one just change the things that are
necessary studies can then be archived
where they're available for sir
purposes and their lockdown for editing
they can always be reactivated if needed
and studies can be exported to
collaborators that are not part of your
database but they have study log and
then they can import the study and see
it as if they ran in house so that's the
basis of our study based functionality
we do have also messaging functionality
internal to the software as well what
our customers say about study log well
they say a lot of nice things I'll say
that in general we're very pleased we
this is an example from Genesis and I'm
not going to go through all of these but
I will say that's being able to push the
data into an aln makes the lawyers happy
so we do work with your existing lymph
systems what we see is this is very nice
uh that this our software saves them
time resources money and allows them to
achieve more results with their existing
staff so what they've been seeing is
that the doubling or even tripling the
number of studies they can perform and
this is consistent with what we see with
researchers at other labs and this
results into a significant net benefit
of optimizing their workflow so they can
screen the greatest number of drug
candidates possible so this is very
powerful we've been around 13 years our
core competency is animal study
management and the software we have a
very consultative and collaborative
approach taking all the best ideas and
best industry practices in building
amend the software and then rolling them
out to everybody as are available our
sister our customers include numerous
academic labs the National Cancer
Institute seven of the top ten big
farmers the world's largest academic
lever the world's largest biotech and
over half the top 20 CR OS worldwide and
2015 we received a bio IT world best of
show award by a panel of bioinformatics
experts and we had the distinction of
being the first animal related software
to ever receive this award so we're
grateful and honored for this
acknowledgement of our approach
so you can contact us at the addresses
here i will be showing the software in
the next phase the presentation thank
you very much
I have now logged into the desktop
version of the study log animal study
workflow software we do have a web
version that does everything that this
one does except for data collection upon
logging in each user sees the studies
that are in the database in this case
all studies are being displayed that
includes all active archive studies
which were locked down for editing it
also includes if I expand this the
studies that are still listed as private
so I don't see those only the people
that I are assigned to those studies see
them studies in various stages of
development such as draft waiting for
approval or not started and I can also
see the active studies and these are all
the studies are currently ongoing and
but I might I want to see all those
studies I might just want to see the
studies that I'm playing a role on or
I've been assigned to so I can click on
the button this is I am assigned to and
I'll see just a list of the studies that
did I have a role on so there that list
is made a little bit shorter and we also
have the option by you see the little
gold stars on the left and when those
are checked you can that makes a study a
favorite study of yours so if you're a
stakeholder within an organization such
as a project manager upper level
management or even somebody that's
essentially principal investigator and
they have several people working on a
variety of studies and they just want to
keep tabs on their favorite studies of
the studies that may be me or more
meaningful to their most important to
them they very easily just take a look
at those of those studies and it's very
easy to simply highlight a study right
click on a study and create a graph so
if I right click on this we have the
options to create survival graphs or
other graphs really as a matter so i'll
just show you an example here of a
survival graph
you
this is for colitis study as i mentioned
study log is used not just for oncology
but it's also used for a variety of
other study types and i can just
actually very easily copy the image to a
clipboard and paste that into a Word or
PowerPoint or Excel document or my email
and distribute that information that way
and this makes it very easy you can also
use this in part of you as part of any
reports you'd like to generate although
our Excel exports and other reports
create their own graph so depending on
what you need that graph may be just
generated automatically but this is a
lot allows you to very very quickly to
generate a graph and view that literally
hot off the mouse I'll close this graph
and I'll open up another graph and this
is a graph of a dose-response study and
what I see are the group means of both
body weights and tumor volumes and we
have the options where we can actually
show the number of animals to power each
time point so you've got an idea as to
where you might want to be your
statistical comparison or statistical
analyses you can actually show the
values you can as you see here we've got
the show sensor data box checked so as I
mentioned before you can censor or
exclude data and by checking this box
any data that I've censored will be
applied at this graph so in other words
we can exclude any data that we want to
exclude from this graph or these graphs
and any of the reports we also the
option to graph not just absolute data
their values but relative values the the
Delta values group means plus or minus
standard error with error bars or not
geometric means medians etc so they're
all available here to be graphed and if
there are dosing those things happened
here
you'll see dosing day arrows now in this
case you see the switch this to a
relative graph and if I'd like to just
basically hide all this information i
can simply hide it excuse me and now i
can paste it into my report if I'd like
to do that so I'll go back to all of the
list of a list of all active studies and
something that's really important to be
able to do is to find study so we're
always looking for information want to
know what's going on on any given day
you see we have a variety of columns
within the this view or screen we can
move any of the columns from one place
to another good move articles over here
I can do that if I'd like to move the
cells over on the side I can do that or
move it back if I want to get rid of a
column entirely so it's not displayed I
can customize my view that way I just do
with that like that so there's a lot of
flexibility here and that applies to all
of the study designs so articles back in
here and now what I'd like to do is show
you how we can find information so if I
want to look for a study with a certain
let's just say cell line I could type in
let's see Colo and I'll see all the
colorectal ones okay there's only one
study there but there's other ways of
searching for studies and we can use our
our boolean search tool so if I want to
type in a search term here such as to
see here her too
the system will look through the entire
database and bring up all the studies
that have her to used on them so if i
want to just simply highlight them and
then generate a report i can do that so
I've got a bioluminescent study those
response study and some others in this
case i can highlight my dose-response
study and generate some reports so i can
show you how we can very quickly get to
the the results and generate some
analyses first report i have well I've
got a wide variety of reports that I can
choose from in this case I'll just run
the preclinical research report which is
essentially a protocol report it has a
smaller number of options as to the
format of the report and choices each
each report has its own and also we have
a variety of report formats based on
different disease areas and model types
such as behavioral science has a
different type of excel export than say
an oncology report so in this case we
see a more formalized protocol report
the protocol and and report output this
is for a contract lab customer that we
created this for so you've got your
table of contents and then details about
the design of the study the objectives
is all this information that has been
entered into the design of the study
gets pushed out here design and methods
the test articles details about the
treatment groups the frequency of
administration of each and if we see all
the tasks that have been scheduled for
the study and if we scroll down here we
see some graphs
so we see a group mean body weight graph
as well as a group mean tumor volume
graph and then down below that we see
actual raw data so the length and the
width and the calculated tumor volumes
along with the body weights so that's
just one example of one report we can
create I'll show you a few more not to
not to go into too much detail one of
our more popular reports is the oncology
report and in this case I can choose to
include the unassigned animals and as
well as maintain the excluded data and
our censored animals and they'll remain
excluded and from this report that will
generate shortly so here we see the
oncology report if I click on the tumor
volume worksheet we see a graph of the
group mean tumor volumes along with
tables of the group mean values and
standard errors we see graphs and tables
for percent to oversee tumor volume
percent inhibition percent delta T over
Delta C and mean percent Delta
inhibition there are other other outputs
or other worksheets here so for example
if you want to copy and paste it into
graphpad you can do that in that format
however we do have the ability to simply
right-click on a study and push that
data into a graph pad format that you
provided us so if you have a template
that you use routinely you can send it
to us we can include that into the
software itself and you can see the same
sort of worksheets with the group mean
bodyweight graphs and tables etc so
again at just one report I'll show you
another example is our consolidated
report so this is for the same study
this is showing group beam tumor volumes
as well as a relative to
volumes so percent change from initial
with the tables and again tables for
mean percent inhibition medians etc and
if we'd like to actually see more of the
raw data side of things I could see the
individual tumor weights the individual
tumor volumes so what I'm seeing down
here on the bottom as I'm seeing the raw
data to link with and high yellow you
could do lengthen with and calculate the
line that way so any formula you use can
be applied but in this case we've got
individual group graphs for absolute
values as well as log values and then
here we see a table of the calculated
tumor volumes along with the animal IDs
and the fates and if I'd like to point
out on the left here we have two sets of
IDs temporary IDs and permanent animal
IDs in this case the temp IDs appear to
be microchip IDs so that is not a
problem to work with microchips the
system just loves it so I have also run
a a group comparison report so I will
say this not everybody likes to do
statistics and you don't have to know
much about it all you have to know is
how to actually generate it and in this
case the system determined whether the
data was parametric or nonparametric on
each of these study days and ones we see
here because we have an ANOVA the data
is parametric in the p-value which is
highlighted in bold is lower than point
05 so that tells us there's likely to be
a difference between these two groups we
don't know which groups until we look at
the post-hoc tests in this case the we
see there's a difference between groups
two and two in groups two and four and
two and one and here's a body weight in
the post-hoc tests also have results so
other other post hoc tests the two keys
and show phase so we can do this for
body weight or for any data type and
they're very easy to generate and a lot
of people appreciate not having to
actually know a whole lot about
statistics if you do love statistics
don't worry we do have the ability to
push the data out into a variety of
formats if you give us an algorithm we
can actually create an output that runs
that algorithm as long as you've got are
installed in house we can run it and
then bring that data back in like we do
with our multi parameter randomization
method or we can just do it using a
report so a lot of options another
report option we have here I won't show
you we have clinical observations a
variety of data exports protocol exports
formulation reports group data I raw
data reports and then here you see
reports that are specific for different
neuroscience models etc so really as a
testament to the flexibility of the
software that we've got such a wide
variety of outputs and of course as I
mentioned before we've got the ability
to let users create their own templates
using blocks of each of these reports
and compile their own custom report so
that's all I'm going to talk about
reporting if if you'd like to see more
and learn more about this please let me
know contact us for a demo and we can we
can show you a lot more so one thing I'd
like to show you is our today's tasks so
that's under the menu and what it does
is for each user based on the log and it
knows who you are and it brings up all
the studies and the tasks that are
scheduled for today so in other words
it's your to-do list for today's which
is nice to come in in the morning and
see what you got going on so I see on
this study number 16 I've got serum to
collect from 65 animals on this imaging
study using ivis I've got body weight
flux values to measure as well as
luciferin to inject I've got a growth
curve where it got body weight and tumor
volume for a number of animals and I've
got a drug combination study where I
have to measure both body weights and
tumor volumes as well as do a number of
dosing to variety of groups and
this top study this dose-response study
I've only got dosing to do and that's
scheduled for specific times so we see
from six to 11 a.m. and you can assign
task to specific individuals so it would
show by which individual that they are
assigned to so I'm only saying things
assigned to me for today I could see
other people's if i click on shows this
show task assigned to other users and I
could see the entire week as well so I
know what's going on not just today but
you know tomorrow on the rest of the
week and this is also useful to check at
the end of the day for most researchers
so that they know exactly what they
might have missed that day so everybody
gets busy running multiple studies so
it's nice to have a place to to check in
and see ok did I get at all you know and
you see the number of tasks that have
been done on the right here under the
progress bar the 0 a lot of tens are out
of 10 tells us none of the doses have
been done but once you see 10 out of 10
you know that they're all been done so
it's really a helpful tool for oversight
as well as the users themselves to that
are running studies or the technicians
to actually manage what their their
schedule is for the day so we can
highlight any of these studies and just
simply open them up I'm going to open up
the efficacy study in this case it's an
IVA study doing some bioluminescence
measuring flux values so we have fixed
doses of luciferin so we can start with
our first animal we could do animal one
by one or group by group or I simply
just highlight and hit the spacebar and
record that I've actually injected
luciferin and if i like what i can do is
right-click and apply that to the entire
group or all the animals and they'll all
have identical date stamp timestamp and
user stamps because every measurement is
is time-stamped and user stamped down to
the second so these would all be
identical which would kind of make sense
you'd 0 sum and then you can go ahead
and run your your animals of using your
IVA system so in this case I can select
a an excel file that has got some data
from some flux data so i will highlight
that copy it going to study log
highlight those fields for those animals
wrong ones the ones with the the little
clocks tell us that those are scheduled
so that's how i know what what i have to
do today so in this case i pasted in
those values there there and if I would
like to actually associate or attach a
hyperlink this is a linked a linked
field so I can actually select a file an
image in this case the original image
and right click on it and I could apply
this image to a number of animals that
so there's I know there's five animals
in this image so I'll do group 1 and a
couple of other animals that are in that
image itself
ok so I've applied that to multiple
animals and if I want to see the image
very quickly and you just double click
on it and there I see it so it's their
associated with with the values and if
we'd like to associate with comments we
could do that as well and I can select
body weights and as I mentioned before
we can create dictionaries that are
specific to data types so we can link
files but we can also show comments so
in this case if I way and animal and
it's an extremely low body weight will
say 15 grams and there might be an
explanation for that so I can right
click and simply say okay well it's not
due to you know anything happened other
than it's gotten a malocclusion so
that's important to know if you're if
you're looking for toxicity or
dose-response you know the animal is not
losing weight due to the treatment but
actually due to a physical problem so
this is just one example of data
collection if we wanted to sacrifice
that animal i could just very easily
right click and enter in a mortality
observation and instead of recording it
is alive i can just say ok we're going
to do a euthanasia let's just say you
know could be simply removed from study
and there we go you see we got a variety
of other mortalities for example animals
that have excessive tumor burden or body
weight loss so you can you can record
that as well if I have another animal
that's let's say lost a lot of body
weight and I don't have a threshold
limit being reached here but I just know
that that's unacceptable so I could just
basically enter in a mortality
observation for it and record that it's
excessive body weight loss so now this
I'm just calculating it my head but on
another study I can actually see where
I've got previous day
yeah and you could see here we've got
tumor volumes in red here that indicate
that the animal previously has exceeded
tumor volumes that are acceptable or
that the animals need to be monitor more
closely so for example if I want a body
weight an animal and put in 25 grams it
will calculate the dose I record the
doe's in this case it's not a fixed-dose
it's actually based on the actual body
weight so the system will calculate the
dose based on the most recent body
weight so I could put in a value here of
12 for the length and then i'll put in
13 for the width which is a mistake by
definition because it would square that
so our system corrects that mistake and
if i have a tumor volume that's very
large i have exceeded the threshold
limit which I seem to need to really be
able to exceed that lets just try
something here so there we've exceeded
the threshold limit which in this case
is 2500 and it tells me that information
so in this case I can right click and
enter in a mortality and record that as
due to tumor volume exceeding the tumor
normal and threshold and if I'd like to
again gonna put any comments about a
tumor while I'm I can do that as well it
would be a different comet menu so in
this case would simply be right click
and then in this case necrotic necrotic
mild necrotic severe or will desales
sort of moderate okay so these are just
some of the things you could do I can
enter in clinical observation so I I can
collect data for all tasks are scheduled
but I'm not forced to do that I can also
have the freedom and flexibility to to
do tasks on the schedule days or to
choose to do them on other day so in
this case I might just want to enter in
Nicole observations right now so i just
select that as a data type and i will
double click on an animal can say okay
this animal happens to be normal but
this animal is not normal and so I'm
going to call up and add in a clinical
observation so we have a clinical
observation dictionary that comes with
the system it can be modified as I
mentioned before users can create the
dictionary super headings such as
locomotor and then see all of the
specific details or observations that
are related to that locomotion so here
we see catalepsy a taxi etc if we look
under respiration we see respiration
related observations so if I say okay
tak the end and I click Add I when I set
the dictionary required that a severity
be recorded in this case we'll say
moderate acne and then that would be
recorded alternatively I could remove
this and do something else I could
record things that are maybe not
clinical observations I could actually
record things like histology histology
descriptions or let's just say the colon
is severely enlarged so i could say okay
colon specify enlarged and i could
specify a size or a score depending on
how i want to set up the dictionary so
in this case maybe we'll just say a
score for and we'll just say at the
distal end i will say to posterior and
that's fine now let's just click add and
then that's in there and recorded should
we hit okay and then save but in this
case I don't want to record it because I
want to keep showing you other
functionality within this this tool and
that is specifically this is very very
much appreciated by researchers and that
is the ability to record where they're
collecting tissue so and how they're
collecting tissue so if we're supposed
to collect tumors and cut half of them
in formalin-fixed some
could put it in the cabinet and then
specify the location the rack the box
add that if I'm cutting that tumor in
half and putting the other half into a
formalin-fixed block that's going to go
into a cassette into a freezer shelf one
freezer one shelf three rack to box to
and click add and then what i can do is
click ok and then I can click out and
then right click right click back on
here and I can then apply that to all
animals and so then I could run a report
and always know where those tissues are
stored and located and if i change the
location i can i can change the location
or if i create new new samples such as
slides that can record the location
those slides as well so that's kind of
the idea around the data collection you
can collect any data type that you want
whether it's scheduled or not you can
collect it as you need to you can select
what you want to do when and the system
will record exactly what you did whether
it was planned or not plant it doesn't
matter it will be in the database now if
I want to change something I i can
change something but if i have the
auto-lock cells box checked you see here
it's checked I can't I can't change any
of that data if I uncheck it now I can
actually go through and change this
value so instead of maybe point 25 I
reweighed the animal maybe it's point 26
so that's an example of ability to to
very easily change data as you need to
it once i hit save that data will then
be committed to the database and then to
change it i need to actually do a formal
data amendment okay so if i close my
computer or my battery runs dead the
data will be parked in the database
where it's preserved but it won't be
committed to the database so you have to
hit save to actually commit it so we do
have a tool to review data and amend
data and that's here available also from
the
view data function so I could actually
do a very quick full expand on this data
so i could take any single data point
and highlight it and if i want to
exclude it this is how our sensor and I
could just basically click turn it off
or if it's not just the body weight
let's just say its body waiting tumor
volume I could do that as well and I
like the tumor volume and I'll exclude
that and exclude all the tumor Williams
let's say due to a necrotic tumor or
maybe I want to exclude the entire
animal and turn turn it off basically
sensor all of the data because i miss
dost it so i could turn that animal off
entirely or exclude all that data in one
one step and then in all the graphs and
reports it'll be excluded there as well
if i need to align asynchronously
collect the data used to hear the align
data by those are tools by which i can
do that I can shift data if I need to
amend a data point it's very easy I can
just simply click highlight and amend
the value and put in the changes along
with my reasons and if I have the
appropriate authority level I can
approve my own data amendments if I lab
technician I don't have that authority I
can propose the amendment to the data
it'll all previous versions of the the
data will be kept in the system so you
always know what the data was if you
change it six times all seven versions
will be there so if i put in twenty i
will get change recalculated and i can
approve it and then it's saved into the
system and all data men its amendments
are accessible and also available in a
variety of different reports so i can
choose to save this data or if i want to
discard it i also have that flexibility
if i made a mistake and measure a bunch
of animals with my calipers and maybe
they weren't zeroed out or my balance
doesn't zeroed out i don't want to go
back and you know delete and rewrite the
data i can just basically discard it
on action and just click this card and
then that data will be excluded and now
i can close i should mention that we do
have the option to show to show previous
data while we're collecting data so you
you have reference data so for example
previous clinical observations or tumor
volumes if that's important to you to
look at why you're collecting data you
can actually have that available for
viewing so going back into the design of
the study i can highlight any study that
i want to take a look at and we'll just
say okay let's just take a look at at
the study so highlight this study the
dose-response i'm going to go into edit
mode and just very briefly to show you
the highlights of the design and then
we'll wrap it up there and do some
questions so each study is represented
by a series of tabs so the first tab is
a general tab you can put in your study
number or name whatever you want to call
it the system can automatically generate
study numbers each of the fields here
you can free text and type in if you
want or just select from what's in the
drop-down menu you can lock these
drop-down menu so users only select from
what's available you can also make
fields required so that they get a
reminder every time they go into edit
mode so you've got a lot of flexibility
it can be as loose as you want or as
tight as you want we recommend like
making your i equip protocol your animal
life or license a required field that's
a good idea just good practice you can
put in your title objectives at the end
of the study you can put in your results
and conclusions which are here which was
since I don't think we finished this
study I don't think we have any results
of conclusions so no we don't but what
if we did they would appear in any of
the reports you put in your dates as as
best you can as you know them obviously
you don't necessarily know when dosing
will begin until you're ready to
randomize and then when you do
randomized basically you just put in the
the dose and begin state
and specify if that's your day 0 if
you'd rather your interest your knock
ulation date beer day 0 however you like
so our personnel tab allows you to
assign personnel to a study so i can add
individual users so i can add a
technician for example Bob from work
group 1 as a study technician and maybe
i'm going to add get my mouse to work
here and then add a a department or a
group of people ask technicians so a
team of people will just say work group
2 and all of the people that have the
technician role or responsible
technician in this case four out of the
five people in that group have that that
role or permission in their profile and
so they can actually collect data on the
study reviews the study design or rather
view the study design they can run
reports but they can't change the design
of the study so only authorized people
can do that which includes the p.i or
the study director and the study
coordinator so study reviewers can just
look at the data they can't actually
collect any data so you have complete
flexibility as an organization to add
new roles which like these and then
define what the permissions are for each
and here's where we can make a study
private and if you didn't want to assign
people to approve the study design you
can check them here and they'll get
messages to approve the design or not
and it will be active once they've
approved it so we can assign the animals
that are going to be used on the study
I'll have all the details about them
this the vendor that they come from the
species and then we've got vendor and
speedy specific strain names because
that nomenclature is important to have
consistency for your euthanasia method
here you see they're identified with
microchips we see the two sets of IDs if
there is any fate or threshold limits
that have been exceeded you would see
here in this case all the animals are
alive and happy we can bring in animals
from previous studies that are left over
let's say unassigned animals and we want
to reuse them for another study you can
do that we can print cage cards from
here I'm not going to do that we can
also print group cage cards as well
we've got a variety of formats that we
can provide you as part of it but we can
also customize cage card formats groups
are very easy to create and add you
can't have any number of animals per
group and fill in all the details you
like about the bet engaging the housing
conditions things that qualify these
these animals as part of the study so no
limit to the number of groups here we
also have our treatments or our test
articles in this case this is a
dose-response study so it's one vehicle
control as you see administered
intravenously with the dosing rule being
ordos volume being 10 mils per kilogram
based on body weight and as you see the
test article we have three different
drugs or dose level or single drug with
three different dose levels also
administered by the IP route but these
are described as test articles as
opposed to vehicles vehicle controls or
negative controls or let's say untreated
controls I get a whole variety of
different descriptors for treatments and
the system will also calculate
formulation information if you choose to
enter in that information that makes
that process significantly easier we
also record the disease induction method
which for oncology studies is usually
going to be a Xena graph or a pdx and
the specific cell line and number of
cells and the volume and that sort of
thing it'll also calculate how much of
each of the components that you need for
example a one to one maître gel hbss
ratio it'll calculate how much volume
you need of each and you record the
location and pertinent information that
five years down the road you might not
remember or maybe forgot to record but
in this case it makes it because
especially if you're cloning a study
this information will be here but to get
details about the
inoculation as well as preparation so
what kind of media use the confluence
etc any sort of samples that you set up
to collect on a study can be defined
here and that this makes it very easy
because you can basically view and
specify the details I didn't show it in
the data collection but in the data
collection one of the sample is to be
collected it actually shows these
instructions right next to the checkbox
like 100 microliters are to be a blood
are to be collected in a red top serum
separate a tube under a nice of fluorine
anesthesia and of course we can also
very easily use our print sample label
generator to create samples that we can
very easily print out in this case for
plasma with all the group and group IDs
and animal IDs accordingly and moving on
one of the most important pages or tabs
in the system is the tasks and
measurements this is where you can set
up threshold limits for body weight so
you know twenty percent or ten percent
body weight loss your tumor volume
information details about tumor weights
it'll calculate net body weight by
determining what the weight of the tumor
is and then subtracting that from the
actual body weight so if you have
threshold limits based on that that can
help you more closely monitor the health
of the animal so this is where you would
add all sorts of tasks we have a variety
of tasks that you can enter in but
basically any numerical value you want
to enter in whether it's a tumor volume
or a food consumption or water
consumption or a custom value like a
serum biomarker or tissue wait necropsy
tasks sample collection tasks
temperature etc etc and the standard
task that we have in the system already
as I mentioned are here and so you can
just simply select those if you don't
have them already so in this case I
could select ok let's put in the number
of metastases and that will then be a
data type that I can then record and
collect and so we've got the unit's
number of Mets and
there it is so we've added that to the
study and then we could set up schedules
and view them accordingly so any task
can have a schedule usually the
schedules differ from task to task so
dosing is usually going to vary relative
to say body weight and tumor volume
measurements so bring my schedule up
here
or it could be that I haven't scheduled
anything so oh I half okay so here we go
so well what I see is a lot of time
tasks as well as body weight in tumor
volumes over time I could show study
days if I like or can show this schedule
in a month view or weepy so easy s in
time tasks so if I see the work week for
you I can see it that way or debut so a
single day so for today from six a.m. to
11am I've got dosing of these drugs
right here and the time non specific
tasks such as body waiting to Merle and
we're not scheduled today I've only got
dosing schedule today so so that is
basically the details of what we collect
on in terms of information on a study
design you've seen how that then
translates into creating schedules for
people as well as those schedules than
showing up as scheduled task in the data
collection screen collecting all that
data then allows you to very easily
generate reports and graphs within the
system and that data is then preserved
into the database so that is my
presentation if you have any questions
I'd love to hear from you and thanks
very much for your attention
okay I've done I'd like that answer some
of the questions that we have have had
posed here so one of the one of the
questions that we have is which program
can be used to build graphics on big
data well I will say this that we have
internally a graphing program as I just
displayed within the application as well
as the ability to pull data in from
multiple studies and apply that on a
multiple on the same graph both
internally and in our multiple report
formats we can push data out into a
variety of statistical analysis and
graphing programs such as our and prism
and you know fast if you need that as
well so we do have that ability so that
was a question from the lean Gomez
there's any other questions I'd love to
hear him and doesn't look like I'm
getting any additional questions right
now but I would like to say that
everyone has different needs within
their own lab whether its large studies
or lots of small single day studies or
long studies or but the software is
applicable to labs of every size and the
time-saving is of course proportional to
the extent and amount that the
software's is actually used so the time
savings are significant and everyone is
usually curious to see how does the
software apply to my own personal
situation or my own labs workflow and
the kind of studies that they're running
and my answer to that is is everyone is
different we have endeavoured to build
the software and is flexible away as
possible so that it is applicable to a
variety of study types as well as
disease areas and we'd be more than
happy to show you on a one-on-one web
demo to actually with with even examples
of from your own you know study types if
you want to
those to us in advance we could set that
up with fur an individualized web demo
and walk you through the software and
see so how it works in your particular
situation so if I that doesn't look like
I'm getting in addition any any more
questions anybody like to type in a
question okay again you can you could
reach me at Gibson at study law com or
you can find us on the web at study law
com and we'll be more than happy to set
up a demo over the web at a time and
date of your convenience so with that
being said I'd like to thank everyone
very much for their time and attention
and their interest and hope we have the
opportunity to meet with you and may be
discussed in any additional questions
you might have so thanks very much and I
wish you all a good rest of your day